to do a wreck I think it happened just
to give you guys a heads up was it
Thursday or Friday it was Wednesday
it was during the attic show okay so
yeah so that means I was on my way to
work
um on my way from work so I didn't get
the uh watch it but I noticed no they
had some highlights took a page out of
Xbox book with the uh you know with the
stealth drop the Metroid Prime wait are
you reply to Xbox
Dave it was clear they had a Stern
release date for that game
you know it worked for this you know
listen why not you know but yeah
I like how Xbox
that was very disrespectful continue the
attack razor remake
I do appreciate though Nintendo for
doing the Metroid Prime actually I'm
contemplating and uh you